Caption: Hey hopefully had a good break so I'd
Caption: like to welcome next sander
Caption: give us a new review of cryptography I'm
Caption: really looking forward to this top cuz
Caption: my idea of cryptography was the Enigma
Caption: machine and Leslie Heath so I'm sure
Caption: things have changed since then yeah
Caption: please welcome Sandra thank you thank
Caption: you by show of hands how many of you
Caption: have seen the movie 2001 a Space Odyssey
Caption: alright that's quite a few you'll
Caption: probably know that one of the main
Caption: characters in the movie is the computer
Caption: that actually controls the spaceship
Caption: which is hell and when the movie came
Caption: out people noticed that Hal is actually
Caption: derived from IBM because if you shift
Caption: the letters from IBM to the left by one
Caption: you get help but the writer of 2001 a
Caption: Space Odyssey said that that was not
Caption: intentional we don't know if that's true
Caption: but there you go
Caption: it is it is however a nice example of a
Caption: very simple encryption method which is
Caption: called the shift cipher but it's also
Caption: known as as the Caesar cipher and it
Caption: bears his name because Caesar emperor
Caption: Caesar actually used this encryption
Caption: method back in the day it is a character
Caption: substitution method
Caption: the idea is to shift all the letters in
Caption: the alphabet by a fixed number of places
Caption: 1 2 or 3 and anywhere up to 26 and then
Caption: basically you've gone around so because
Caption: a C goes to B etc decryption means doing
Caption: the opposite so a goes back to be etc
Caption: now you might wonder how this would be
Caption: secure you have to remember that back in
Caption: the day not a lot of people actually
Caption: knew how to read or write lesson but all
Caption: communication would be in Latin so by
Caption: adding a simple method of encryption
Caption: Caesar was able to you to create very
Caption: secure communications and in the case of
Caption: Caesar we actually use the shift of
Caption: minus 3 the most well-known form of
Caption: shifting is probably our T 13 and it has
Caption: the added benefit of being symmetric so
Caption: encrypting is basically exactly the same
Caption: thing as decrypting so for instance if
Caption: you encrypt
Caption: d it goes to Q but if you encrypt Q it
Caption: goes back to B so it's in that sense
Caption: it's symmetric character substitution
Caption: also forms the basis of the device that
Caption: I will talk about in the rest of my talk
Caption: which switches briefly mentioned the
Caption: Enigma to German Enigma the Enigma probe
Caption: performs a proper character substitution
Caption: in the sense that it doesn't just do a
Caption: shift you type a letter and a certain
Caption: lamp would light up so for instance you
Caption: would type the T and it would show up as
Caption: a king it's also symmetric in the sense
Caption: that when you use the same key the same
Caption: settings for the machine if you then
Caption: type the encrypted message you will get
Caption: the plaintext back so it's very very
Caption: handy in that sense now I'd like to
Caption: point out that from an electrical point
Caption: of view the Enigma machine is incredibly
Caption: simple it basically consists of a
Caption: battery of a switch and a lamp close the
Caption: switch and the lamp will turn on this is
Caption: of course a gross simplification because
Caption: the actual Enigma used 26 switches and
Caption: 26 lamps and a bit of additional I would
Caption: call it electronics but wiring to dunya
Caption: encryption it is actually so simple that
Caption: I was able to build a tiny little
Caption: encryption device like this which uses
Caption: exactly the same core principle it is
Caption: extremely limited because it also had it
Caption: only has four characters and it actually
Caption: only uses three keys but the principle
Caption: is exactly the same it shows that the
Caption: character never encodes to itself just
Caption: like the Enigma the only thing that this
Caption: one doesn't do is go through all the
Caption: keys which is something that he enigma
Caption: actually does automatically now the
Caption: smarts of the Enigma are in the way the
Caption: electrical circuit is closed using those
Caption: 26 keys and 26 lamps and this is done by
Caption: a set of rotors and each rotors perform
Caption: each rotor performs a certain character
Caption: substitution now each enigma m3 had five
Caption: rotors of of which three would always
Caption: use at once on top of that it had to
Caption: static wheels and
Caption: over there and then reflector wheel over
Caption: there and basically the current would
Caption: flow through the entry wheel through
Caption: these three rotors back flew through the
Caption: reflector wheel and back again through
Caption: the routers and the entry wheel and then
Caption: a lamp would light up and I'd also like
Caption: to point out there's something else here
Caption: which is the plug board but abacab extra
Caption: but the power of the enigma was that
Caption: each time you press the key one of the
Caption: rotors would actually rotate one
Caption: position and at some point that one
Caption: would actually rotate another one as
Caption: well I'll get back to that assumed so I
Caption: just briefly mentioned the flood board
Caption: this was only used for the military
Caption: enigma there were also a next month
Caption: enigma is used for postal service's way
Caption: before the war but this wasn't this was
Caption: an addition that actually made it much
Caption: more difficult to to crack and the
Caption: plugboard perform two additional
Caption: substitutions one on the way in and one
Caption: on the way out
Caption: so the roses would step a base on the
Caption: key presses and just like a plane or
Caption: odometer that you would find in a car at
Caption: some point a router on the right would
Caption: basically make the router to its left
Caption: also step forward one step and again for
Caption: the router next to that and what happens
Caption: is that the actual character
Caption: substitution of the machine changes
Caption: every time you press the key and this
Caption: means that when you press two keys to
Caption: two times Genki you will not get the
Caption: same result so you press t1 so you might
Caption: get K you press T again you might get
Caption: repeat for instance and they are what
Caption: makes is very strong is that because you
Caption: you cannot sort of correlate the input
Caption: with the output it makes frequency
Caption: analysis very difficult so for instance
Caption: the letter e it's very common in the
Caption: English language and if you could find a
Caption: letter that's basically in the encrypted
Caption: message this is often you could infer
Caption: that it might be the letter e so that
Caption: doesn't work in this case
Caption: now each day the Enigma would be set up
Caption: by using predefined routers so three
Caption: inkay
Caption: of m3 in a predefined position one of 26
Caption: and the predefined ring Stella and the
Caption: ring sterling basically meant how the
Caption: next router would turn over on top of
Caption: that there was of course the blackboard
Caption: setting and the Germans always used 10
Caption: substitutions always but in other words
Caption: the key for the day was determined by
Caption: those 4 settings now I'd like to talk a
Caption: little bit about key space and key space
Caption: according to Wikipedia refers to the set
Caption: of all possible permutations of a key
Caption: now remember the shift cipher it only
Caption: has a key space of 26 this one only has
Caption: a key space of 3 is with remorseless
Caption: reading so if the Allies forces would
Caption: not have had any knowledge of the rotors
Caption: internals then the key space would have
Caption: been enormous because just think about
Caption: how many ways you could wire up a single
Caption: rotor in fact it's about 1.5 times 2 to
Caption: the power of 20 10 to the power of 25
Caption: it's ridiculous but the a large force is
Caption: that he knew how the rotors were were
Caption: wired but the good thing for the Allied
Caption: forces was that the Germans didn't know
Caption: that the Allied forces knew this so they
Caption: overestimated the power of their Enigma
Caption: so I'd like to point out this guy it's a
Caption: Dutch guy his name is karakov and he
Caption: came up with a principle that said a
Caption: cryptosystem should be secure even if
Caption: everything about the system except the
Caption: key is public knowledge so this is why
Caption: modern cryptographic methods are always
Caption: publicly scrutinized there is very
Caption: little to no safety in security through
Caption: obscurity but the Germans may have
Caption: overestimated the security of the Enigma
Caption: by sort of ignoring this law they should
Caption: have assumed that the Allied forces had
Caption: everything about the Enigma accepted
Caption: please let's do a quick calculation
Caption: about em three key specs so we have to
Caption: pick three out of five rotors that gives
Caption: us a total of 60 combinations each
Caption: router has 26 positions so that gives us
Caption: 26 to the power 3 equals 17,500 176 then
Caption: we have to bring Stalin which only
Caption: applies to two of the
Caption: which gives us another 676 combinations
Caption: but now it gets wild because when we
Caption: factor in the plugboard which always had
Caption: 10 substitutions we get a whopping 1.5
Caption: times 10 to the power 14 permutations so
Caption: we have to multiply these together and
Caption: then we get the total key space of the
Caption: m3 which is about one point zero seven
Caption: times ten to the power 23 which equates
Caption: to approximately 77 bits which is pretty
Caption: good for you know for that time and
Caption: because he m4 used three routers out of
Caption: eight plus a force one it was actually a
Caption: 291 times stronger so it had a key space
Caption: without 84 bits now let's do a quick
Caption: recap so far we've talked about
Caption: encryption and decryption character
Caption: substitution and the shift cipher
Caption: frequency analysis key space security
Caption: through obscurity and character flaw now
Caption: let's talk a little bit about cracking
Caption: the Enigma how many of you by show of
Caption: hands have seen the movie the imitation
Caption: game with Benedict Cumberbatch wow
Caption: that's impressive
Caption: so this movie basically revolves around
Caption: Alan Turing and he played a pivotal role
Caption: in cracking the Enigma and most of the
Caption: work of maybe all of the work that was
Caption: done to do this was done at Bletchley
Caption: Park in the UK and chewing was one of
Caption: the first people to be recruited there
Caption: I'll get back to him a little bit later
Caption: because there is nothing easier than
Caption: cracking an encryption system then
Caption: having the keys and the Allied forces
Caption: were lucky enough to have the keys once
Caption: or twice then got the codebook somehow
Caption: from the Germans so that gave them the
Caption: opportunity to actually decrypt the
Caption: messages that were sent and the good
Caption: thing was that it gave them information
Caption: about what are the Germans actually
Caption: sending or what kind of messages are
Caption: they sending and can we maybe use that
Caption: later on and it turns out that they
Caption: could and one day God's hand of the keys
Caption: that was called a pinch now I would like
Caption: to point out a flaw in the design of
Caption: enigma and this is called a double step
Caption: so each time the rightmost at some point
Caption: when the rightmost wrote it turns out it
Caption: would also turn
Caption: the one to its left and at some point it
Caption: would also turn off the bunch of its
Caption: left but due to our fault in the
Caption: mechanical design at some point the
Caption: middle road to the Sheep turn off twice
Caption: and as a result this would have the key
Caption: space what this would still leave plenty
Caption: enough room to not make it completely
Caption: crackable just like that so it wasn't
Caption: that big a deal but it did also help a
Caption: little bit in statistical analysis the
Caption: electrical design however also contained
Caption: a bit of a flaw and that was which also
Caption: mentioned about this device is that a
Caption: character never encodes onto itself so a
Caption: tee would never encode him to a tee and
Caption: the Y would never encode them to a Y etc
Caption: so as a war raged on the code breakers
Caption: get more and more knowledge of the
Caption: messages that were actually sent so for
Caption: instance they found patterns in the
Caption: messages in the original messages so a
Caption: lot of the messages would actually end
Caption: with how Hitler so these kinds of known
Caption: texts or soon known texts they were
Caption: called cribs and the Germans actually
Caption: sent a wedding report every day at 6
Caption: a.m. it had a very specific format so
Caption: let's take for example the crib better
Caption: Burak which means weather report in
Caption: German so if an encrypted text looks
Caption: like this then you can infer that
Caption: certain places would not be the
Caption: encrypted words crib that was there
Caption: because in this case the eye matches but
Caption: the I can never encrypt itself so this
Caption: would be a wrong position to start to
Caption: start checking now Alan Turing let's get
Caption: back to him for a bit he came up with a
Caption: critter analytic process called member
Caption: isthmus and this was specifically
Caption: created for German types of messages for
Caption: sorry German Navy types of messages
Caption: because of the process they used for
Caption: encryption so first of all all messages
Caption: for a single day used the same key which
Caption: were those for settings I told you about
Caption: earlier this was called a goon Stalin
Caption: but the actual message would be
Caption: encrypted using a Ken grouper or sort of
Caption: an indicator which was sent twice at the
Caption: beginning of each
Caption: now all those can group and would be
Caption: sent with the same method same key for a
Caption: single day now this a process of bambor
Caption: isthmus considers whether encrypted
Caption: messages are in depth which is sort of a
Caption: measure of correlation because all those
Caption: can group and/or indicators were
Caption: encrypted with the same settings they
Caption: were all in depth and it's really helped
Caption: with getting information about the
Caption: settings further for the Enigma for a
Caption: certain day at the end I'll have a slide
Caption: with some resources and there's also a
Caption: link to a site that has like really
Caption: in-depth information about this process
Caption: in case you are interested in it now
Caption: Alan Turing also understood that the
Caption: only way to break enigma every single
Caption: day was to automate the process so they
Caption: built a machine called the bombe which
Caption: is basically named after polish device
Caption: that was used to crack earlier Enigma
Caption: machines so the bomb basically used a
Caption: method of elimination it it tries to it
Caption: basically parallel parallel eyes going
Caption: through all the router settings so what
Caption: you're looking at is basically a
Caption: parallel computer in a sense and what it
Caption: does is trying to juice the plugboard
Caption: settings that's the one that actually
Caption: caved in a comet's power and it is
Caption: electrically which made it really really
Caption: fast and it would start by assuming a
Caption: certain blackboard setting like for
Caption: instance a goes to G and then based on
Caption: the message that it was fent as fat it
Caption: would then trying to juice other
Caption: settings like H goes to R or Peters o
Caption: until it founds the contradiction
Caption: for instance a goes to I don't know yet
Caption: you can't have a go to to two characters
Caption: that that's not how it works we already
Caption: know that so when you found that
Caption: contradiction you knew it was wrong but
Caption: Alan Turing understood that all the
Caption: other plug board settings that you would
Caption: find in that particular one that they
Caption: were also wrong and you didn't have to
Caption: check them
Caption: now there is another video sync receipt
Caption: of the enigma that makes cracking a
Caption: little bit easier so you know how you
Caption: know how all the roads is basically
Caption: advanced based on the rotor before but
Caption: the leftmost rotor hardly ever rotates
Caption: especially because messages were almost
Caption: never longer than about 650 characters
Caption: so you could learn quite a lot by just
Caption: focusing on the right two rotors I'd
Caption: like to think that the bomb they very
Caption: well have been the first special-purpose
Caption: computer ever and it was based on much
Caption: of chewings ideas about computing and
Caption: algorithms and things like that the
Caption: entire effort of the crips in an enigma
Caption: was an incredible feat of human
Caption: ingenuity and it was based in science
Caption: engineering math and statistics now
Caption: there's a lot more to be said about
Caption: Ehlinger think for instance about the
Caption: Turing machine or the Turing test
Caption: there's also a lot more to be said about
Caption: the Enigma itself but the purpose of my
Caption: talk was not to give you like a
Caption: comprehensive overview of the Enigma in
Caption: the efforts of cracking in or about
Caption: curing I did however address some
Caption: concepts of cryptography that you might
Caption: want to further study so I do encourage
Caption: you to find out more about Alan Turing
Caption: about the Turing machine the gaming man
Caption: and about cryptography as a field of
Caption: study we've come a long way since
Caption: Cynthia enigma even though for the time
Caption: it was a really good machine so I have a
Caption: look at the list of resources which I'll
Caption: put up next and if you really want to
Caption: know about Alan want to know more about
Caption: Alan Turing I would say consider reading
Caption: his biography that we all Rafi a bad
Caption: start because you will find out that
Caption: much of his work did not occur in a
Caption: vacuum as hardly anything ever does and
Caption: if you want to play with an Ingmar like
Caption: a proper one online at least then just
Caption: search for enigma and you will find it
Caption: but there's one key takeaway I'd like to
Caption: leave you with any encryption system can
Caption: be broken given enough time and effort
Caption: but when you have the key you don't even
Caption: need to go through that
Caption: so to tie it in with our everyday life
Caption: how are you treating your passwords I
Caption: hope do you keep them secure so here are
Caption: the resources take a picture if you
Caption: would like to get more information but
Caption: for now this is it thank you for
Caption: listening
Caption: [Applause]